sean mcvay could make his offense work
with
a lot of different quarterbacks jared
goff is their guy mcveigh inherited goff
but they've paid goff and made him a
franchise quarterback let's listen
to this question and answer from the
aftermath of
sunday's loss to the 49ers and it was on
sunday that mcveigh called out goff
for not taking good enough care of the
football he had three turnovers
here's mcveigh on monday the question
and answer let's listen and we'll react
on the other side
when jared's having a tough time like he
had in miami like he had
yesterday at any point during those
games do you consider
putting him on the bench if not for a
series or the rest of the game
you know um if i thought it was going to
be the best thing to just take a deep
breath and step away then i'd say you
know maybe but not in either of those
situations because both of those
reflected
you know kind of having an opportunity
where there was enough plays made to get
back in it
um you know dolphins game maybe a little
bit different but i thought it was
important to be able to play through
some of those things learn from it
especially just based on some of the
things that they were activating
defensively
there was a lot more to that where he
got into details about how
the game against the 49ers you know it
was 17-3 but then this happens this
happens this happens this happens the
next thing you know we're leading the
game
so goff's mistakes weren't fatal to the
point where you had to get them off the
field
and their backup is john walford
don't ask me where he went to college
don't ask me how they got him i assume
he was undrafted if he was drafted he
was drafted late in the process it's not
a name that jumps off the page
so you have to consider benching
possibilities in light of who
the replacement would be but chris i was
struck by that response
because if you have a short list
franchise quarterback
and you get asked that question what's
your response
he's our yeah what the hell are you like
what are you talking no
and you don't have to be a bill
belichick type jerk about it and roll
your eyes and say we're on to cincinnati
like he did when he got a similar
question about tom brady six years ago
but if this is clearly unequivocally
unconditionally your guy that's a
question that has a
much shorter answer the answer is
no he's our quarterback we don't remove
our franchise quarterback from the game
for a backup
that most people have never even heard
of yeah no i i mean
agreed i i was surprised to originally
read the long answer to that question
too you know i think that sean mcvay
first off
hey he's he's great i mean he's honest
and he talks to people and gives us real
answers and i
really respect that about him it's not
coach speak and bullcrap
and yeah i think again i don't think his
support for jared goff
is publicly gonna waiver i think there
he got a little in too deep of i think
he's trying to tell you yeah i
recognize it's not good from jared goff
but
here's the reasons i wouldn't have done
it in these two games or why i wouldn't
have benched it
so i think he's kind of acknowledging
like yeah it's not been good i'm not
happy about it
but you know here's the reasons i
wouldn't bench him because miami was
doing this type of stuff and
you know last week blah blah blah blah
blah blah either way
the fact of the matter is come on i mean
we know the real thing here
they were stupid to pay jared goff that
much money jared goff is a good football
player you can
obviously win but i mean how many times
do we have to say it
when the game gets put on his shoulders
it's
underwhelming if they can't run and
speed sweeps and play action pass and
bootlegs
jared goff is not going to beat you
throwing the ball
dissecting your defense surgically
destroying you with accurate passes
escaping the pocket and making plays and
you know mcveigh understands that that's
fine i think he knows what golf is
but he's just saying okay if this is
what you are then don't then take care
of the freaking football
you can't just throw a ball into richard
sherman's you know
chest land in no man's land you got to
have feel for the pocket hey this is the
49ers they got a good front four
you can't just stand there and get
waylaid when people are around you
and throw a pick six that way and then
at seven three and we're driving for a
field goal or a score before the half
you can't scramble for three yards and
fumble the freaking football and i think
that's what he's saying like
hey i like it easy for you i know what
you are
the one thing i need from you is to take
care of the football
and that's all i'm asking he knows he's
not going to be on the homes or desean
watson or whatever
and i think that's where that long
answer probably came from there
well and and uh let me just say this
before we go to break i remember two
years ago
when i was making the argument that
jared goff should be the first guy in
this new age of quarterbacks where you
can find them
in the draft if you need to and if
you're a great coach you can find a guy
who can run your system
that someone needs to say to one of
these guys and this is one of your
pet peeves this progression of
quarterback hangs around
quarterback does well enough quarterback
gets gigantic contract it makes him one
of the highest paid players in league
history
right because he's a quarterback yeah
and we're going to pay him all this
money because
that's who we have and we're going to
make him our guy sometimes it blows up
in your face right and
we're seeing it happen with the eagles
and carson wentz
and it could happen still with the rams
and jared goff guys taking one
and two goffin wentz respectively in the
2016 draft
right well you know like two like yeah
we're in this old school thought i think
it
i think it's about to change of this era
of like you're talking about
we got our franchise guy we're never
gonna change do any of that
why why first off how many teams do we
have to see have rookie quarterbacks be
successful because their teams are on
rookie contracts
like the old age adage of oh we gotta
let our young quarterback develop on the
sidelines for seven years before we can
play him
he doesn't know how to snap these guys
are ready i mean everybody's ready
i mean look at all of them every year
that that's done
you can win and go to the playoffs of
the rookie quarterback
definitely a second year quarterback so
i don't know why teams get married
you know in that way either i really
don't and
of course the salary implications and
everything like that but
yeah i hear you mike i think that
point's very real
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports